[Music]
[Applause]
our next guest Jeff Fletcher he is a
writer for the Orange County Register
covering the angels and his new book
show time is the inside story of shohei
uttani and the greatest baseball season
ever played it hits bookshelves and
available online beginning July 12th
before we bring Jeff in let me just
bring back one of my favorite sounds
it's Otani from Friday night
hammered destroyed that baseball
it's just it's different it's different
Jeff Fletcher joins us uh have you heard
a ball leave a bat like that before
uh well Tony said a couple like that
before so another player Mike Trout is
it a couple like that too but okay for
the most part uh not a lot of times I
had mentioned the other time I heard
something different jock Peterson when
he came up for the Dodgers and he hit a
couple of home runs where it just
sounded different what is it with Otani
with that power
well you know he's got just a kind of a
god-given uh ability to
put the right torque on his uh his body
for lack of a better word to where he
gets you know the bat stays back and it
just flips through really quickly and uh
if you get it at the right path then it
puts backspin on the ball and that just
makes it Go a really long way
if you look at his pitching and is
hitting are they similar in in Talent
you know uh I think his pitching is
better he's really never had a bad
stretch as a pitcher he's had like one
bad start here and there uh this year
was the first year he ever had two bad
starts in a row
uh so the pitching the only problem has
been injury hitting he does have you
know every once in a while I'll have a
bad month it'll strike out too much
he'll
you know swinging pitches out of the
Zone you'll get a little pull happy and
ground out too much uh and then you know
he corrected but and it kind of goes
back and forth which is like a lot of
hitters but but pitching wise he's much
more consistent I just wonder
are the angel is the right team for him
is are the Angels the right team for
Otani for baseball as well because we've
seen Mike Trout and we've seen three
playoff games
and look I would love that he stayed
with the angels but I don't know if
they're any better than they were
whatever how many years ago
yeah that's certainly a fair question
the angels are not a great baseball team
right now they have not been since
either of those guys have been there uh
say for one season and obviously it's
better for baseball if those guys are in
the postseason
but you know it happens uh you know Tony
Gwen had a long career where he didn't
do much in the postseason Ken Griffey Jr
we didn't see too much in the postseason
so you know it just happens in sports
and and it's hard to manipulate it to
where you say I want this guy to be in
this organization so we see him in the
postseason and you know I'm sure Major
League Baseball would love to do that
but uh you know this is what we have but
is he loyal to them that like at some
point you see Damian Lillard in Portland
like you got to look around and go what
am I doing here
ohtani hasn't I mean he's still young
but I don't know if he looks around and
says to Mike Trout
you know what am I doing here
yeah I mean obviously Otani uh is pretty
closed closed off with the media about
what he really feels and uh all we know
is that he he likes Anaheim he likes the
people around him and you know when he
when he picked the Angels they weren't a
great team so obviously if when he first
came to the United States if going to
the World Series was objective number
one he never would have picked the
angels in the first place I think he
likes it in the atmosphere he likes the
people that are around him and I think
that still counts and I think if the
Angels give him a ton of money that's
certainly not going to hurt
um
you know look recently at Manny Machado
and Bryce Harper I mean they signed with
teams that had not exactly been having
parades year in and year out because
they were they liked the atmosphere and
they got a lot of money so I think it's
still possible that that is what happens
with otami all right let's uh go to the
brawl the melee Donnie Brook give me the
back story on this because it's rare
when you just have something of this
magnitude that's based off what happens
in the moment yeah there's definite
backstory uh Mike Trout first of all has
killed the Mariners for his entire
career 53 homers against the Mariners is
most against any team the most homers
any player hit against the Mariners uh
he said more homers in Seattle than any
active visiting player has hit in any
ballpark where he's been a visitor last
weekend they played a five-game series
in Seattle which had a makeup from the
lockout and he hit five homers in the
series uh he killed him all all uh four
of them were game-winning homers
and one of those
Scott service basically got killed in
the media because he didn't
intentionally walk him you know it was
an X trainings they pitched to him he
had a homer
you know obviously it doesn't look very
good so now you fast forward to Saturday
trout comes up as the tying run in the
ninth inning and obviously they're not
going to pitch to him
but instead of just intentionally
walking him they pitch around him and
the first pitch or the second Pitch goes
right over his head and trout is pretty
annoyed with that uh after the game he
was as upset and angry as I've ever seen
him in 10 years of covering him hmm
so if you're the angels and you see Mike
Trout is that upset you have to do
something about it basically so I think
what happened uh
on Sunday is uh they used an opener
it's for the game and uh he came out
there and he threw pitch to Julio
Rodriguez kind of right behind his head
and then in the second inning he threw
on a Jesse Winker hit him right in the
hip and uh and pretty much
that was that it was it was on and uh
you know I don't think that the trout
thought the Mariners were throwing at
him intentionally but he certainly
thought that if they were just pitching
around him that they should have done it
in a safer way or else just put up four
fingers and let him go to First and he
was mad about it and you know I think
the Angels definitely the way they're
going they needed some kind of a spark
and uh certainly this is a was a perfect
opportunity to do something that was
gonna get people fired up and uh I think
it was extremely predictable
which is another reason I think you
could kind of blame the umpires for this
because I talked to uh to the umpires
after the game and and I said well were
warnings issued before the game based on
what happened Saturday night and they go
oh no we didn't think that was enough to
to Warrant warnings well all of us in
the Press Box knew there was going to be
a fight so for the umpires to to say
that they didn't think there was enough
to have warnings I think is
something's missing there
and if they would have just said like
before the game all right anybody throws
at anybody they're getting kicked out
and when Lance throws the first pitch
behind Julio Rodriguez he kicks him out
right there it's probably over so that's
what happened
do you like the baseball places itself
I mean it's kind of silly but uh you
know it's it's what we have it's it's
what the players expect and
uh
you know I think for the most part
people don't get hurt
um
I mean it is kind of silly when you try
to think about it try to explain it
somebody's not a baseball fan they just
go why are they you know it's not his
fault that he hit a lot of homers
against them so why would you be mad at
him you know and you know it's kind of
dumb I never understood that I and I
I've called out pictures I say it's
cowardly especially in the American
League when they didn't have to come to
the plate that you're gonna you wanna
hurt me because I I hurt you in a way
that it was in the within the rules and
I just like or the guy after the guy who
homers that's even dumber when you throw
out the next guy I know I always feel
bad for that guy you bad behind somebody
who's like Aaron judge and then you're
like oh damn you just homered now I'm
Gonna Get You know somebody gonna budge
the tower here but yeah and then you see
by the time the bullpen gets in like it
feels like everything's done and then
the bullpen comes in well then they have
to play a role here as well uh what kind
of suspensions are we looking at
I mean that's a great question uh I
think that there are certainly some of
the main guys are probably going to get
you know five ten games uh just off top
of my head maybe more there were some
pretty big punches thrown I've seen a
lot of these baseball fights and I
haven't seen
punches to this degree in too many of
them and uh Jesse wanker also flipped
off the crowd like multiple times with
both hands walking out off the field so
I'm sure that's going to earn them a
little extra change paying to Major
League Baseball so
uh and the managers obviously are both
going to get suspended so uh it's going
to be interesting to see
Jeff good luck with the book and thanks
for joining us we appreciate your time
all right thanks for having me that's uh
Jeff Fletcher he is uh the angels beat
rider for the Orange County register and
his uh new book show time inside story
of shohei uttani greatest baseball
season ever played on bookshelves
starting July 12th